odile marcellin france regrette avec
nous ce matin bonjour madame la
présidente du pôle martinique de
l'université des antilles un bonjour
monsieur viol dont il fonctionne et
surtout bonjour à aux martiniquais à nos
étudiants nos élèves qui reprennent le
chemin de l'école aujourd'hui et le
chemin de l'université et vous occuper
cette fonction de président du pôle
martinique depuis mars dernier
votre première rentrée en tant que
patronne de ce point avec le message
resserrer le personnel autour de la
mission de l'université forme et
pourquoi insister dessus autant c'est
une notion qui s'est diluée au fur et à
mesure je vais tout d'abord dire que
nous effectuons une rentrée aujourd'hui
qui est importante
je suis vraiment résolument optimiste
concernant cette rentrée universitaire
pour notre pôle universitaire également
nous avons effectivement connu des
périodes difficiles nous en sortons et
aujourd'hui nous avons une communauté
universitaire qui veut se projeter de
l'avant qui veut répondre aussi un
message que voulait faire 6 2 aussi à la
mission de service public qui est la
nôtre et qui est de former nos jeunes et
de les préparer à la à leur avenir
professionnel
alors cette crise c'était quoi c'est le
faire de ces réunions bien sûr nous
n'allons pas nous voiler la face il ya
une à fait acquis ya effectivement
empoisonné la vie de l'université mais
nous en sortons c'est une affaire qui
est résolu au niveau de l'administration
le cneser l'a rendu son verdict et là la
communauté universitaire et toute la
population martiniquaise n'attend qu'une
chose c'est que le verdict soit rendu
également au niveau judiciaire
le lâche vert est en train de se
poursuit
le la justice fait son travail nous
attendait encore des imbéciles attendons
effectivement que cette affaire que le
verdict soit rendu que l'affairé soit
jugée pour tourner définitivement la
page et je fais confiance à mon pays à
la justice de mon pays
pour atteindre ces objectifs qui nous
permette de rebondir ce que nous sommes
déjà en train de faire au niveau de
l'université et de nous projeter de
l'avant on va terminer rapidement avec
cette histoire du ciraig bien madame
france au grain
vous devez rembourser une somme
aujourd'hui c'est quel montant sur
combien exactement 10 millions d'euros
que nous avons à rembourser nous en
avons déjà remboursé près de 5 à 6
millions ce qui grève bien sûr un le
budget de l'université et qui ralentit
les projets que nous avons pour pour nos
étudiants pour notre communauté
universitaire
donc vous voyez bien il est
indispensable que nous finissions avec
cette affaire que nous en tirions les
leçons et que surtout nous mettions au
coeur des activités de l'université
l'éthique la déontologie universitaire
qui nous permettent de former nos jeunes
et de remplir notre mission de service
public et surtout de contribuer
fortement nous sommes pilier pour cela
au développement économique de nos
territoires
alors lui aujourd'hui ce village campus
services hors main souvent évoqué le
manque de places dans les universités
françaises concernant les étudiants ici
il ya encore une marge de manoeuvre on
peut encore s'inscrire
est-ce que c'est pas tout simplement
parce que cette affaire c'est réglé a
fait beaucoup de désordre que de
l'université des antilles n'a pas la
cote
le constat qui est fait aujourd'hui donc
vendredi nous avions une hausse des
inscriptions de 10 % par rapport à
l'année dernière
donc les élèves les parents nous font
confiance font confiance à leur
université
je le remercie pour cela je leur dit
vous avez raison de nous faire confiance
je ferai des deuxièmes choix troisième
choix university l'université des
antilles c'est une université comme
toutes les universités françaises qui
forment bien avec des enseignants des
enseignants chercheurs des personnels
administratifs et techniques qui sont
compétents qui réalisent leurs missions
qui sont volontaires et ce ne sont pas
des deuxièmes choix non avec 92 licence
et master dans l'offre de formation ici
sur le campus de chercheurs ainsi si
carter fouillole vous avez quand même
odile france roy au grain marcellin vous
avez quand même recensé un problème au
niveau des licences c'est le bas c'est
là que le bât blesse
qu'est ce qui gêne exactement au niveau
des licences cake quelle est cette
difficulté que vous avez recensés ce que
nous constatons c'est et c'est un
constat qui est national
c'est le fait que les jeunes
ont des difficultés à passer le cap de
la première année de licence
c'est un phénomène qui est national et
qui est accentuée chez nous c'est un
problème que nous prenons à bras le
corps puisque nous travaillons en
partenariat étroit avec le rectorat nous
avons réalisé une réunion académique
post bac à la fin de l'année
universitaire dernier avec l'ensemble
des proviseurs de lycées des inspecteurs
et en présence de madame la rectrice un
partenariat extrêmement fort avec
l'académie pour justement comprendre et
mettre en place les outils qui
permettent aux lycéens de s'insérer dans
leur vie universitaire au mieux de
comprendre au plus tôt quelle est leur
projet professionnel
et pourquoi ils sont en train de
réaliser des études qu'ils ont choisi
donc il faut un véritable accompagnement
des outils et je peux vous assurer que
nous sommes déjà en train de mener et de
valider des projets intéressants avec le
rectorat qu'est ce qui se passe
exactement lorsqu'on a passé son bac on
a l'impression de se retrouver sur le
campus de chercheurs dans une sorte de
club med
aucune université net club med
l'université est un lieu de savoir les
études les jeunes d'aujourd'hui ne sont
pas suffisamment perdant motivation il
ne faut que nous puissions leur les
projeter dans l'avenir qu'il comprenne
en croit leurs études vont leur
permettre ensuite de trouver un travail
en martinique où ailleurs dans le monde
et pour cela il est important que nous
communauté universités avec moi vice
président de l'université jeu j'accentue
les partenariats avec
le monde socio-économique avec les
institutionnels et cela en collaboration
étroite avec la collectivité
territoriales de la martinique
nous menons un travail partenarial qui
est extrêmement conséquent et qui nous
amène effectivement à définir les voies
qui permettent le développement
économique
et on croit l'université et
singulièrement le pôle université de la
martinique est habilité à aider pour
répondre à cette mission il ya une offre
de formation qui est quand même très
important entre martinique il ya le
great il y aller
il a les organismes de formation
professionnelle il y à l'université il
n'y a pas concurrence entre tous ces
mondes l'université délivrent des
diplômes universitaires elle est la
seule à pouvoir le faire donc l'ensemble
des partenaires de la formation
nous devons être ensemble et nous devons
fédérer l'université doit fédérer
l'ensemble des partenaires les chambres
consulaires également les diplômes qui
sont délivrées au niveau des greta au
niveau 2 au niveau 2 par exemple de la
ccm ou d autres organismes doivent être
mises en place en collaboration avec
l'université nous voyons trop souvent
encore des des partenaires du territoire
mettre en place des formations des
diplômes avec des universités
hexagonales ou d'ailleurs
nous avons la capacité en martinique en
guadeloupe également donc à l'université
des antilles de ramener vers nous c'est
ces organismes et de leur proposer des
partenariats c'est ce que nous faisons
alors
madame france au grain au moment où on
parle de la mondialisation moment on
constate qu'il ya de plus en plus de
martinique et qui partent de plus en
plus tôt d'ailleurs pour leur cursus ne
serait ce que pour rentrer en classe de
lycée quelle carte peut jouer la
martinique lorsqu'on lorsqu'on sait
qu'un bain c'est tellement facile
aujourd'hui de s'inscrire à l'université
de stockholm aller aux états unis
allaient à genève aller en espagne puis
c'est tellement plus excitant pour notre
jeunesse de de s'exporter de s'expatrier
étudié à l'université des antilles cela
ne veut pas dire s'enfermer sur un
territoire
notre université est ouvert sur le monde
nous avons des structures qui le
permettent le bureau de la recherche
internationale et nous proposons à nos
étudiants des semestres d'enseignement
dans des universités étrangères de 3par
nous recevons chez nous des étudiants
internationaux nous en avons 85 importe
ce premier semestre qui viennent et qui
en interaction avec nos étudiants et
bien les enrichissent de cultures
différentes et cela c'est une réalité il
était pour autant aussi que nous
puissions retenir ces étudiants
justement qu'ils veulent partir dès la
première année
par exemple en mettant en place des
coopérations avec les universités
étrangères pourquoi pas sa fonction à
des gens bien sûr cela fonctionne il ya
déjà des diplômes que nous menons
partenariat avec d'autres universités
nous avons un phénomène important c'est
celui de nos étudiants qui partent
étudier au québec il est souhaitable
pourquoi pas innover et aller justement
via ses universités leur proposer des co
diplômation ainsi un étudiant de
l'université des antilles pourra à la
fois étudié en martinique et étudier au
canada mais cela nous permet de garder
nos étudiants nous avons aussi une une
volonté d'ouvrir nos formations à
l'international par le numérique
donc il s'agit pour nous de développer
l'enseignement à distance et nous avons
un exemple concret qui est réussie c'est
celui du masters français langue
étrangère qui est dispensé dans le monde
entier par la voie du numérique
très bien merci d'avoir été avec nous ce
matin un premier invité de la saison sur
dans son caddie odile france croit au
grain odile mars la france au grain
y danse du pôle martinique de
l'université des antilles merci d'avoir
été avec ne rappelle le village campus
service aujourd'hui à schoelcher merci
bonne journée
merci à vous monsieur vu le ton
[Musique]